Speaker 1: So I don't know how many of you saw or
remember the recent film with Leonardo DiCaprio?
Don't look up. There's this incredible scene
where they bring on one of the scientists who
has discovered that there's this comet or meteor.
I don't remember heading towards earth. And they
say this is happening. It's going to kill
all of us. And the news reporters who are
oh, man, I don't remember the actors, Tyler Perry
and Mann. Forget now. In any case, we're going to
look at it. They say, you know, we want things
to be positive here, like, okay, yep. Right. But
we're all going to die if we don't do anything.
And they go, No, but it's we like positive news
here. And yesterday on JB News in response to the
insane historic heat wave that is plaguing much
of the United States in Europe, there was almost
the exact same sort of discussion. No, we warm is
nice. We like warm. No, people will die. No. But
it's so nice when it's warm out. We're going to
look here first. Ben Phillips, put this together.
This is really good. First, it's going to be the
segment from the satirical film Don't Look Up, and
then it'll be yesterday's segment from JB News.
And they're basically the same thing.
Speaker 5: All right. Are looking here, are we not
being clearer? We're trying to tell you that
the entire planet is about to be destroyed.
Okay, well, it's you. Just something we do around
here, you know, we just keep the bad news light.
Oh, you see, John, you're outside enjoying the
sunshine. It's not too hot, is it? No, it's.
It's absolutely lovely. It's, what, 20 degrees
out here? It's perfect. But on a serious note,
folks. By early next week, you can scratch
20 degrees. It could well be 40 degrees.
I think there will be hundreds, if not thousands
of excess deaths and extra shots that I know.
Speaker 1: That's bad news. You don't want that.
Speaker 5: In front of me. All right. So we all
like nice weather, but this will not be nice
weather. This will be potentially lethal
weather for a couple of days. It'll be brief,
but it'll be brutal. So, you know, we can.
Oh, yeah, it's so. This is so, John. I want us to
be happy about the weather and everything. I don't
know. What if something happened to meteorologist
to make you all a little bit fatalistic?
Speaker 1: Yes. It's called the reality.
Speaker 5: Harbingers of doom, because all
of the broadcast, particularly on
on the BBC, every time I've turned
on anyone's talking about the weather,
they're saying that there's going to be
tons of fatalities. But yeah.
Speaker 1: I don't know. Whenever I
look at more reputable news outlets than ours,
they're acting like this heat wave is a bad
thing. Can't we just be happy about the warmth.
Speaker 5: We always had? Hot weather, John.
I mean, wasn't the 76 the summer of 76
that was this hotter? This wasn't it?
No. And we are seeing more and more records more
and more frequently and more and more so daily.
So, yeah, some people always hark back to
the summer of 76, which was a freak event
40 odd years ago, 40 years ago. But heatwaves
are becoming more extreme. This is yet another
one which is coming down the track towards
us and you know, I don't think we should.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So anyway, GB News is a right
wing channel backed by Discovery. Now Discovery
and the Discovery has done really good stuff on
science and climate and so on, but they are one
of the backers as well as some non-UK financiers
for GB news. And I mean, it's it's the same thing
as the scene from Don't Look Up. Isn't this
nice? It's sort of like the right wing thing of
listen, trees like to breathe carbon dioxide.
So isn't more carbon dioxide a good thing? And
it has become, you know when don't look up first
came out it was a it was like an extreme version
of this bury your head in the sand sort of. Trump
is a parody of Trumpism. Now, the scene we just
saw from The Real News is as or more crazy than
what we saw in the film, Don't look up. It's truly
bizarre stuff and reality mirroring fiction at
this point in a really horrifying and scary way